on va finir avec le dernier talk de la
journée par anaëlle santé dont dix
années elle est passionnée par la
relation et la communication
elle a rencontré pas mal d'obstacles sur
son chemin de maman qui l'ont amené à
faire de cette passion son métier à
nesle aujourd'hui accompagne des parents
et des professionnels de l'enfance que
ce soit des enseignants des éducateurs
des assistantes maternelles etc
à la découverte d'une communication
consciente pour plus d'efficacité
d'équilibré dans leur relation adulte
enfant elle a été formée par l'atelier
des parents elle anime entre autres les
ateliers de communication faveur et mas
liche
bienvenue à nesle bonjour lorsque je
suis devenu par an pour la première fois
j'ai fait la connaissance d'une personne
que je ne connaissais pas encore moi
alors pas le mois phi phi de pas non
plus le mois femme soeur ou amis le mois
par an 2 au départ je me suis senti
plutôt confortable dans ce rôle là j'ai
envie de dire même compétentes
mais ça c'était au départ petit à petit
monfils est passé du bébé à l'enfant et
moi je suis passé de la maman plutôt
sereine à la maman complètement bousculé
parce qu'elle découvrait en elle-même
doucement je me suis retrouvé à dire et
à faire exactement ce que je m'étais dit
que je ne dirais pas et que je ne ferais
pas avec mes enfants
j'étais pourtant plein de bonne volonté
mais voilà je voulais construire quelque
chose
une relation saine avec mes enfants
j'avais décidé d'être une maman qui
communiquent
je vous en parlais un petit peu après
mais je me suis quand même demandé ce
que je pouvais bien semer dans ma
relation avec mon enfant avec may cry
avec mon irritation presque constante
certains jours
et avec mon impatience je vous ai dit
que je voulais être une maman qui
communiquent
je l'avais décidé bien avant qu'il
naisse et en fait j'ai expliqué
j'expliquais je ré expliquer je vous ai
dit que j'expliquais en fait je voulais
tellement expliqué que j'expliquais
peut-être trop je parlais peut-être trop
ça c'est le piège du parent qui veut
être un parent qui communiquent et vous
savez quand on n'explique trop ou plutôt
trop longuement avec un enfant qui a
trois quatre ans ça donne ça il va vous
écouter à les 15 secondes puis va
décrocher
s'il ya des jouets qui traînent par là
il va les prendre et en plein milieu de
votre long monologue il va faire et vous
avez franchement l'impression qu'ils
étaient en train de se moquer de vous si
la 13 14 ou 15 ans il va vous écoutez 5
secondes
oh bah oui il a 13 14 ou 15 ans
d'expérience derrière lui et autant
d'années à subir vos bons vieux pavé
indigeste et le pire et le plus beau
dans tout ça c'est que même vous quand
vous êtes arrivé à la fin de votre long
monologue
vous ne vous souvenez parfois même plus
de ce que vous étiez en train de dire au
départ aujourd'hui j'accompagne d'autres
parents à la découverte d'autres parents
et d'autres professionnels de l'enfance
à la découverte d'une autre façon de
communiquer certains l'appellent la
communication bienveillante d'autres la
communication non violente ou positive
moi je préfère l'appeler je préfère le
terme de communication consciente
on va voir comment ça marche ça hop
alors je reviens sur ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure après avoir été bousculé
par ce que je découvre en moi même j'ai
fait l'expérience dans nature
dié faber et mas wisches du nom des deux
auteur du best-seller parler pour que
les enfants écoutent écouter pour que
les enfants parlent et j'ai réalisé deux
choses la première c'est que j'étais une
bien moins bonne communicante que ce que
je me l'étais imaginé au départ et ça
dans toutes mes relations
pas seulement dans ce que je vivais avec
mon enfant la seconde c'est que je ne
mesurais pas encore l'impact que mes
mots d'adultes pouvait occasionner sur
le comportement et le désir de coopérer
de mon enfant donc je reviens au terme
de communication consciente
le dictionnaire nous dit pour conscient
qui a une pleine et claire connaissance
de ce qu'il fait ou éprouvent de
l'existence ou de leur aide de la
réalité de quelque chose lucide
donc si on reprend notre termes de
communication consciente
il s'agit d'avoir pleinement conscience
de l'impact de notre communication sur
la relation la motivation la coopération
et les cimes de soin de notre
interlocuteur ayant conscience de ces
choses je peux donc travailler ma
communication et faire preuve de
bienveillance envers mes enfants mes
parents mes amis mes collègues et envers
moi le terme de communication consciente
vous remarqué qu' il n'est pas fait
mention de compétences particulières les
siens juste d'avoir conscience de
l'impact de notre communication
ça m'est déjà mon la pression
ça ne signifie pas communiquer
consciemment ça ne signifie pas que je
ne ferai plus d'erreurs que je ne me
laisserai plus mes enfants avec mes mots
mais que lorsque ça arrivera et ça
arrivera encore de nombreuses fois même
si je fais attention à ma façon de
communiquer je pourrais agir en
conséquence
j'en prendrais réel réellement
conscience de mes erreurs de mes propos
blessants et je pourrai rétablir la
communication rétablir la relation
il y a quelques années j'ai découvert
les travaux de masaru emoto qui est
docteur en médecine alternative au japon
mazars ou à moto a mis en lumière à
travers différentes expériences l'effet
de la pensée et des émotions sur l'eau
je vous invite à faire vos propres
recherches sur ces travaux et moi je
vais vous expliquer rapidement de quoi
il s'agit certains connaissent peut-être
la fameuse expérience du riz il s'agit
de prendre deux bocaux identique dit et
d'y déposer du riz cuit qui contient
donc de l'eau ils sont stockés
de la même manière que ce soit pour le
contenant le contenu la température ou
la lumière pour la seule chose qui
diffère c'est ce qui est communiqué à
l'un ou à l'autre donc sur ces bocaux il
est pratiqué deux choses sur l'un des
pensées positives
je t'aime tu es merveilleux merci sur
l'eau des pensées négatives
je te déteste tu es nul etc
et donc il a démontré à travers ces
expériences que la nature de nos
émotions et nos pensées faisait réagir
le différend différemment alors là vous
voyez sur ces deux bocaux vous avez donc
d'un côté je te déteste de le côté je
t'aime on s'est écrit en japonais je
pense mais au bout d'à peu près un an ça
donne ça je suis assez curieuse et du
coup après avoir fait mes propres
recherches
je me suis demandé ce que ça donnerait
si je faisais cette même expérience sans
les mots je t'aime je te déteste mais en
utilisant avec l'un une communication
traditionnelle c'est-à-dire une
classique comme la majorité t majorité
des parents parlent à leurs enfants et
avec l'autre une communication
consciente
il ya un peu plus de moi j'ai donc pris
soin de prendre de beaucoup identique
j ai déposé du riz d'une seule et même
cuisson puis j'ai tiqué étiqueté sur la
communication traditionnelle sur l'autre
communication consciente régulièrement
pendant ces deux mois j'ai pris l'un et
l'autre de mes pots puis j'ai repris ou
imaginer des situations de la vie
courante avec des enfants par exemple
une crise de colère un mauvais bulletin
une dispute entre frères et soeurs une
réponse insolente une maladresse une
chute une demande non écoutés des larmes
à l'entrée de la salle de classe etc
j'ai voulu rester équilibré d'enjeux
dans ce que je communiqué donc j'ai
décidé de ne pas partir dans des
extrêmes ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
avec mon pot communication traditionnels
j'ai refusé de dire des choses comme je
te déteste j'aurais aimé ne pas t'avoir
parce que ce ne sont pas des mots
courants dans la bouche de la plupart
des parents
avec mon pot communication consciente
j'ai décidé de ne pas jouer au parent
parfait parce que nous sommes bien
d'accord il n'existe pas aussi j'ai pris
la décision de volontairement manqué de
bienveillance de me laisser emporter par
la colère mais de revenir absolument
ensuite présenté des excuses et rétablir
une communication saine donc là vous
voyez au bout de cinq jours mon pot
communication traditionnels c'est le
premier dans lequel est apparue de la
moisissure
alors que l'autre oh là vous voyez la
moisissure vous avez là du verre mais là
on le voit peut-être pas sur l'écran
mais il ya de la mousse blanche alors
que l'autre semblait toujours à ça je
dois quand même vous dire que quand j'ai
commencé l'expérience
une partie de moi était un peu sceptique
du coup quand j'ai découvert la
moisissure dans mon pot communication
traditionnels je me suis dit waouh
j'ai pris quelques photos au fil des
jours donc là je vous montre au bout de
vingt jours mon pot communication
traditionnels donc il a commencé à
moisir à plusieurs endroits montpon
communication concentre semblait
toujours à ça alors vous voyez il ya
quand même des petits voilà ce qui
m'étonne pas étant donné que de temps en
temps je me suis laissé aller
alors je peux vous dire que l'expérience
a été plutôt sympa parce que du coup
quand j'étais plein de colère à cause
d'un comportement de mes enfants j'ai
atteint minutes et j'y allais pied alors
là je me déchaînés je suis à mon pot
tout ce que je leur dis pas eu là vous
voyez donc au bout d'un mois
mon autre communication traditionnels
était comme ça il sait il s'est mis des
espèces de cloques blanchâtre à
l'intérieur et l'odeur était nauséabonde
alors que mon pot comme unique à sion
consciente lui était comme ça il s'est
passé quelque chose d'un petit peu
étrange
dans ce pôle à l'os est vraisembablement
séparés pour rester en surface et
l'odeur elle était inconfortable mais
pas nauséabonde 58
or la gelée ouvert pour faire la photo
mais j'aurais préféré ne pas l'ouvrir
régulièrement j'ai entendu mes enfants
demandaient leur papa papa qu'est ce
qu'elle fait maman là haut dans sa
chambre à qui elle parle
bah oui il leur a répondu très vaguement
ol par la cpo dry du coup je me suis dit
qu'une petite explication en plus ce ne
serait pas trop histoire de pas les
laisser avec l'idée que leur maman par
la dépôt dry comme ça sans raison
particulière et mon fils aîné a eu envie
de tenter l'expérience lui aussi donc
régulièrement il va parler à son premier
pot de riz comme il parle habituellement
à son petit frère et à l'autre comme il
faudrait qu'il lui parle
idéalement je vous invite vous aussi à
faire vos propres expériences et en
tirer vos propres conclusions
j'ai en revenir aux résultats je pense
que nous pouvons sérieusement nous poser
la question de l'impact réel de nos mots
sur notre commune y est sûre pardon sur
nos corps et sur notre et sur notre
santé mais je laisse ça aux gens qui
sont de la partie
ce serait intéressant de pouvoir faire
ce type d'expérience avec des examens
médicaux en parallèle mais déjà revenons
au domaine de la communication
posons nous la question de ce que nous
serons dans nos relations familiales
parce qu'il me semble évident que notre
façon de communiquer n'est jamais sans
conséquence demandons nous si notre
façon d'écouter invite au partage ou à
la fuite et notre façon
de demander de l'aide d'annoncer que
c'est l'heure du repas sent-elle le
désir de coopérer ou non nos façons de
réagir au comportement inacceptable de
nos enfants sent-elle le désir de les
modifier ou bien aurait-elle tendance à
amplifier l'inacceptable
j'ai quand même envie de vous dire que
ça me semble important de préciser la
communication consciente ne permet pas
de faire coopérer coûte que coûte les
enfants s'est tenue une baguette magique
ni de la manipulation mais elle met en
place un climat au sein duquel une
dynamique de coopération se met beaucoup
plus facilement en place c'est c'est le
principe de la réciprocité
il ya une chose surprenante est à la
fois révélatrice que j'ai pu observer en
atelier lorsque je fais des jeux de rôle
avec des parents je leur demande de se
fondre dans la peau des enfants et
ensuite je leur demande comment ils se
sont sentis un mot parmi des dizaines
d'autres revient régulièrement
infantiliser le dictionnaire nous dit
pour infantiliser traité comme un enfant
quand nous sommes traités comme des
enfants nous nous sentons accablé nul
méprisés et je pourrais continuer encore
longtemps ce constat pour moi c'est le
signal que quelque chose ne va pas sinon
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se est-ce qu'on
utiliserait ce mot là pour dire qu'on
comment on se sent quand on est traité
comme eux 1
quand j'ai décidé d'adopter un regard
neuf sur la parentalité j'ai aussi
réalisé que je devais sans aucun doute
changer la façon dont je percevais mon
rôle j'avais tendance à endosser malgré
- un rôle répressif en faisant l'impasse
sur ce qui aujourd'hui me semble évident
mon rôle c'est aussi et surtout de
transmettre
je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote qui illustre bien ça
lorsque mon fils avait 22 mois un été il
a lâché le mot ou plutôt le gros mot
vous savez celui qui vous écorche les
oreilles
le premier celui qui vous fait aussi
réalisé que vous allez vraiment devoir
changer votre façon de communiquer est
votre vocabulaire maintenant
il a fait tomber son jouet il a dit
alors là je me suis sentie saisis
pendant quelques secondes je n'ai même
pas réussi à bouger
puis j'ai bondi à hasnon non non non on
dit pas ça ce n'est pas beau c'est un
gros mot les gros mots il ne faut pas
les dire c'est impoli vous rappeler les
bons vieux pavé indigeste
il m'a regardé il a rigolé et il a
répété
j'ai tout essayé j'ai expliqué
gérer expliqué je me suis fâché j'ai
fait ma tête choquée j'ai tenté
d'ignorer rien à faire et à un moment
quand même je me suis dit qu'à 22 mois
ça ne voulait pas dire grand chose
c'est interdit etc savait pas vraiment
de sens et qui est aussi que pour lui
qui avait 22 mois les codes de la
société
ça voulait pas dire grand chose non plus
donc un jour quand même je me suis
réveillé je me suis dit mais ton rôle
ici c'est pas un rôle répressif ton rôle
là c'est un rôle d'enseignement de
transmission j'ai attendu qu'il le dise
encore et c'est arrivé il a fait tomber
son jouet il a redit je me suis
blessé je lui ai dit quand on est agacé
de faire tomber son jouet on peut dire
zut zut zut zut ou saperlipopette
il m'a regardé il a rigolé et il a dit
père lipopette whaou
on avait réussi cette anecdote pour moi
c'est un point de repère et elle me
rappelle une chose fondamentale dans mon
rôle de parent c'est que chaque conflit
chaque comportement inacceptable est une
occasion pour moi de me positionner
comme un enseignant de transmettre est
aussi une occasion de regarder vers
l'avenir les solutions dont on a besoin
pour que ça fonctionne à l'avenir plutôt
que constamment me concentrer sur les
erreurs du présent ou du passé
au départ je me suis dit que toutes ces
recherches
l'évolution et la modification de ma
façon de communiquer allez vraiment être
bénéfique à mes enfants qu'ils allaient
se sentir plus écouté plus épanouie plus
considérer aussi la grande surprise
c'est que la première personne à qui ça
a fait du bien de communiquer autrement
de communiquer consciemment
c'est à moi c'est beaucoup plus
valorisant d'être dans un rôle de
transmission et d'enseignement que dans
un rôle d'interdiction et de répression
je me sens beaucoup plus épanouie et
beaucoup plus compétentes
lorsque jeu lorsque ce que je sème et
cohérent et même si je dépasse encore
souvent les bornes
même si il m'arrive encore trop souvent
de semer des tomates alors que je tient
tellement à semer et à récolter des
courgettes
je veux me rappeler d'une chose c'est
que je suis au début du chemin et j'aime
bien illustré ça comme ça
la parentalité c'est un grand voyage
plein de rebondissements sur mon chemin
je trouve des cailloux parfois même des
rochers et s'il m'arrive d'être
découragé parfois je me dis est up pause
toit fixe tes yeux sur ton objectif pour
garder la bonne trajectoire mais de
temps en temps jette un coup d'oeil dans
le rétro et voit tout le chemin que tu
as déjà parcouru tu avances et c'est ça
qui est important
la parentalité consciente c'est ça avoir
conscience de être lucide sur l'impact
de ma communication sur les relations
familiales et vous qu'avez vous envie de
semer dans vos relations familiales
merci pour votre écoute